people have known that experience can
change the brain ever since it became
known that the brain was the seat of
consciousness thought and experience and
so I would say that for hundreds of
years has been known implicitly that the
brain must undergo change because of
course is the brain is the physical
object by which we generate our
consciousness and ourselves then there
must be some physical change happening
in the brain so in that sense I think
neuroplasticity has been known
implicitly for centuries but I think
it's really been in the last few decades
that has become really appreciated
exactly what happens in the brain so
about a little over 50 years ago a
Canadian psychologist named Donald Hebb
suggested the specific idea that
experience could change the brain in
ways that that perhaps there'd be some
pathway that gets activated an order of
events that gets turned on when we
experience something and that when we
recall it we are perhaps playing it back
and have suggested that and before him
even before him the pioneering
psychologist William James suggested it
and you can even find the suggestions of
this the hints of this in writings of
Thomas Hobbes and even Aristotle so it's
been in the last 50 years or so that
this suggestion that's been around for
millennia has turned into a very
concrete suggestion about neural
pathways so that's neuro plasticity in
the adult brain then there's also neural
plasticity in response to injury and
also during development and all these
things are facets that have been studied
facets of neuroscience that have been
studied over the last few decades and is
becoming really appreciated how much the
brain can change
when challenged we can do more and
everyone knows this and when in the
absence of challenges we don't
necessarily reach our full potential now
I don't know that that necessarily means
that stress per se is good for the brain
what I mean by stress is very
specifically the secretion of steroid
hormones these hormones that turn up
when we are under some low level
pressure when we're not allowed to sleep
or when we're under some kind of bodily
stress where we are put into some kind
of adverse condition for long periods of
time certainly pressure can make us
perform better but chronic stress has
been demonstrated to to slow down the
birth of new neurons to reduce the
plasticity of dendrites and so there are
physical consequences of chronic
exposure to stress hormones and and
those long-term effects of stress are
mostly unlikely to be very good for us
desk a bottle of pills that I picked
them in Chinatown once that are called
brain enhancer pills and I keep that
sort of thing around sometimes my office
is basically a joke a lot of these
supplements have no demonstrated
positive effects on brain function and
that includes ginkgo biloba and includes
other supplements that you can take
that's one problem another problem that
of course is these supplements aren't
controlled for what's in them and so as
a result if you buy something like let's
say st. John's wort there is tremendous
variation in what you're getting when
you buy those things so even the claimed
pharmacological agent that's in them may
be present in highly variable quantities
and something that we would never accept
in some fda-approved drug the rule of
thumb for foods that may be good for the
brain is that things that are good for
your heart are good for your brain so
it's again this principle of good for
your heart good for your brain and
examples of that include green leafy
vegetables they include not having too
much in the way of saturated fats
because that improves your circulation
or you get older and your brain lives
off of oxygen in the blood and so you
need blood and so when your heart's not
getting the oxygen your brains not
getting the oxygen one category of foods
that seems to be somewhat helpful is
antioxidants so for instance blueberries
especially wild blueberries have
antioxidant properties and they seem to
have some kind of protective effect on
cognitive function as we get older
omega-3 fatty acids are good for both
the heart and for the brain and in fact
I myself take omega-3 fatty acids the OL
all these things you can take I mean
just to put in perspective the only
things that I make a point of eating are
those and and blueberries I like
blueberries
a lot of therapies well I'll be honest I
don't really know a lot about
demonstrated effects of these therapies
like art therapy and music therapy on
the brain I think one major mechanism
that is worth thinking about is the idea
that these therapies reduce stress one
thing that has been demonstrated is that
stress hormones are bad for the brain so
for instance sleep deprivation leads to
the secretion of stress hormones being
in danger I mean stress stress hormones
are stress hormones arose and the stress
response arose evolutionarily to be
something that works briefly if you're
in if there's danger or if there's
something that's caught your attention
and you need to get away from it the
idea is that your certain systems in
your body shut down like your immune
response and the idea is that you got to
shut down the unnecessary things so you
can get it away from danger quickly so
that's the normal biological
evolutionary history of stress hormones
but now in modern times we have
situations in which stress is always
present and so one major way that these
therapies may work is by simply reducing
the secretion of stress hormones which
is good for the brain stress hormones
when chronically present can damage the
brain
it's not exactly it's not fully
understood what it is that exercise does
that's good for the brain the empirical
observation is that the one of the best
things you can do to keep your brain
alive and healthy is fitness training
things that get your heart rate up the
kinds of things that hear about getting
on the treadmill for three times a week
for at least 20 minutes in each session
that's a classic way of getting fitness
training and that's been demonstrated to
improve brain function especially in
older people the mechanism is not known
here are the two major candidates one
candidate is simply improving blood flow
to the brain and again it's back to the
heart brain principle things are good
for your heart or good for the brain
another major mechanism that's been
suggested is the secretion of a
signaling molecule whose job it is to
allow dendrites to grow and to be
plastic and this gets back to what we
were talking about before about
neuroplasticity this molecule is called
brain derived neurotrophic factor and if
you know what a neurotrophic factor you
know from the name what this does it's a
factor that's made in the brain that
causes neurons to grow it's a trophic
factor and that factor has been
demonstrated to improve plasticity and
dendrites and one hypothesis that people
are investigating is the idea that
exercise by triggering the secretion of
bdnf this neurotrophin factor may lead
to increased plasticity and improved
brain function
question because existing drugs like the
ones that you mentioned are all about
the plumbing and the mechanics of
especially in men of sexual performance
something that cuts to the heart of who
we are is loving or sexual beings is the
feeling of love and that's a whole other
category and major signalling molecules
in this category are molecules such as
oxytocin and arginine vasopressin
oxytocin and vasopressin are secreted
when we feel feelings of romantic love
they're also secreted when we feel
feelings of love towards a child so for
instance mother's when they hear their
baby cry will feel their milk drop and
the mechanism of that is the secretion
of these molecules to cause milk to be
secreted and so it's possible to to
reproduce feelings like that those same
signaling molecules are also important
in generating a feeling of trust so for
instance people who take oxytocin in the
form of a nasal spray exert more Express
more trust when playing some negotiating
game with somebody and so now we're
talking about molecules that can affect
our emotional responses to other people
and that seems to cut somewhere to the
heart of what it means to be loving or
sexual
there's a subjective report that that
meditators report right feelings of
peace feelings in being able to focus
there are many versions of meditation
and the version of meditation people
practice leads to different effects so
for instance Buddhists report a
particular state of object lyst
compassion so feeling compassion without
any specific object without a person as
the target one thing that's been
observed experimentally is that when you
put people into a brain scanner and look
to see what happens in their brains it's
possible measure very large electrical
oscillations and the brains of say
Carmelite nuns experiencing mystical
union with God or experienced Buddhist
practitioners entering this object list
compassion state and what's observed is
that you can see these oscillations
which basically are the result of
neurons being active in sync with one
another and at being active more or less
in cycle with one another Buddhist monks
can achieve an oscillation of that and
what's called the gamma frequency band
that's only found in non expert
meditators when they're having seizures
okay so these people can do something
extreme with their brains and I'm not
sure that it reveals anything about the
nature of reaching enlightenment or the
benefits of meditation but I think that
one thing is very interesting about it
is finding a neural signature that shows
exactly which parts of the brain may be
trained when people learn to be very
good at these things and I think that
scientifically that's a rich source of
questions for investigation